Aluno: Vamos para o antigo pessoal.
Aluno: Onde é ele?
Professor: O Solho.
Professor: Suzu.
Professor: A gasta é o Sim.
Aluno: Eu vou arrasar ali, né?
Professor: Eu vou apresenta hoje.
Professor: É uma apresenta hoje.
Professor: Ah, certo, superhats!
Professor: É.
Professor: Vamos lá.
Professor: Você não vai preparar isso também, mas é um projeto para generar o som.
Aluno: Você não seja como você pioneers
Professor: ou autres eh!
Professor: Eu vou morçar mais, eu vou morçar assim.
Professor: Eu vou morçar assim.
Professor: Eu vou morçar mais.
Professor: Eu não sei se eu não me cala.
Professor: Eu não me cala.
Aluno: O que você tem?
Professor: E o estudo, o estudo, o estudo.
Professor: E aí, cara!
Professor: É, é um voo!
Professor: É um voo!
Aluno: É o que ele ia passar, mas vai pegar uma mesa para a brisa solta.
Aluno: É um portamento bom, senão?
Professor: É.
Professor: E aí, minha pegada!
Professor: Um coronador!
Aluno: Eu não sei o que é isso.
Aluno: Não sei o que é isso.
Professor: Não me faz tanto nisso.
Professor: Eu vou ficar na barra.
Aluno: Aqui é tudo que vamos botar.
Professor: Hmm!
Professor: Vai lá, vai lá.
Aluno: E aí?
Professor: Eu estou aqui, estou aqui, estou aqui, estou aqui, estou aqui, estou aqui, estou aqui
Aluno: Tinha dois mais lá, quando minimalifei um bom e全部 que é doido
Professor: É uma coisa muito boa.
Professor: Ei, Mariana, azul e preto.
Professor: Quem não precisa.
Professor: Eu estou te dando um pouco.
Professor: Estou procurando um cair.
Professor: Não estou.
Professor: Não estou procurando um cair.
Aluno: E é tudo que eu ando.
Professor: Eu quero!
Professor: Eu vou contar uma só porra.
Professor: Eu não vai ter um quarto a pouquinho.
Professor: Eu quero um porra.
Professor: Um, um, um, um, um, um.
Aluno: Ainda, você é a mão?
Aluno: Você é a mão?
Professor: Agora está a garota de cá, então...
Aluno: O que é isso?
Professor: Apenas de nada.
Aluno: O que você tem?
Professor: mas essa toda assim não é uma coisa
Aluno: mas tem mata, não é?
Professor: Eu não aguento bateria de tropa.
Professor: Não aguento.
Aluno: esse é o que está fazendo.
Professor: é um cameraman
Professor: é um caminhardinho
Aluno: E aí?
Aluno: Eu não sei se você é o que é.
Aluno: Essa é a sinal da comertura, mas eu não sei o que é isso.
Aluno: Eu não sei o que é isso, mas eu não sei o que é isso, mas eu não sei o que é isso.
Aluno: Jogado tu?
Professor: Não!
Professor: Vamos!
Professor: Salve, pes, do treino, vamos!
Professor: é você que eu não posso fazer.
Aluno: Eu sou o ministro do Fóil de Inúio e eu sei que a gente pode ficar
Professor: ali na hora de suavear regarded.
Professor: É muito importante.
Professor: Muito importante.
Professor: que se esqueçam de tudo.
Professor: Então, ele é mais um forte.
Aluno: É mais grande que o que é um grande anda.
Professor: É muito grande que é um grande anda.
Professor: Vem!
Professor: Ah, eu não vou!
Professor: Não vou!
Professor: E eu sou a escapacia.
Professor: Eu sou a escapacia.
Professor: Doas mais seis.
Aluno: O que é isso?
Aluno: E aí?
Professor: E não é mais fácil.
Aluno: É o que é fazer.
Professor: É que é ter que ficar na verdade.
Professor: É que é tão estranho.
Professor: Tá, tá, tá, tá se que o jogo.
Professor: Ele está com muito mais.